Robert Keller on the eve of another
court appearance for accused killer
Robert Tellis Rita Reed says she's
hoping the judge keeps him in custody
what would it mean for you if he is able
to post bond
um
be frightening and be frightening
tell us the Clark County public
administrator is accused of murdering
review journal investigative reporter
Jeff gearman Jeff is um and feel so
strongly about he actually listened Reed
is the assistant public administrator
she and other employees worked with
gearman to expose problems under the
leadership of Telus Reid ran against
Telus and beat him in the Democratic
primary she faces a republican to win
the seat in November our goal was to get
our office back on track she says
complaints to the county and Union about
Telus bullying employees went nowhere he
became more emboldened in his behavior
and treatment and she saw a side to tell
us which she says most people haven't I
saw tremendous rage there were several
incidences where he came into my office
in a rage
and I and the circumstances didn't
warrant that at all when the work
environment continued to be toxic you're
working on pins and needles and you hear
footsteps coming in and so you tense up
she says she and her co-workers turned
to German they exposed a possible
inappropriate relationship with a
subordinate Telus made social media
posts critical of the stories and then
on September 3rd gearman was found
stabbed to death outside his home did
you suspect Rob immediately immediately
immediately Metro Police say DNA found
underneath gearman's Nails matches Telus
and the elected officials SUV shoes and
clothing are also tied to the scene you
ever feel a physical threat from him
there I was very intimidated I think
many people were she says she and
gearman told each other to be safe but
she never imagined his work would cost
him his life Jeff was
so amazing for us and for our department
and to this community and we will
forever be grateful in Las Vegas Vanessa
Murphy 8 News Now